this video is sponsored by manscape.com
this
is the single best arc of jojo's bizarre
adventure i've ever seen
by far before i jump into this review
let it be known that prior to picking up
the material
for the purposes of this review i had
never really heard anything or seen
anything about jojo's bizarre adventure
diamond is unbreakable oh only well okay
that's not exactly true
i did know the name mostly because years
back when i said i didn't like jojo's
bizarre adventure
everyone and their grandmother
aggressively insisted i check out this
particular part because
and i quote dude diamond is unbreakable
is the sort of jojo story people who
don't like the first few like
which is a really weird thing to say an
even weirder way to sell you on a
particular story but it did pique my
curiosity fast forward three or four
years later and here i am now having
completed phantom blood battle tendency
and stardust crusaders all of which i
expected to dislike on the outset but
instead ended up loving for vastly
different reasons which
brings me to today where i stare down
the barrel of easily one of jojo's most
popular parts
it's unlike anything that's come before
it and it's exactly what i love in a
good story
i'm toy not mark and these are my first
impressions of thoughts on
and review for the creepy mysterious and
tension-filled fourth outing by araki
this
is jojo's bizarre adventure diamond is
[Music]
unbreakable
[Music]
once again because araki loves to write
ridiculously long stories i'm gonna have
to split this one into two parts the
manga you see it's
174 chapters that's almost twice as long
as one piece's longest arc so
even i'm not that crazy with that said i
found the perfect place to stop in this
video and i'll be covering the second
half as well as its climax
next week but enough about that this
week i had to read
five thick boys to discuss the first
half and you know what
this is by far the weirdest part of jojo
i've read and
definitely the weirdest manga i've
opened not just because of what the
story
contains but because of what the volume
did in volume 5 of diamond is
unbreakable i got
free bonsai seeds to clear this up i
didn't order
any bonsai seeds with my diamonds
unbreakable
set this is off to a bizarre start but
you better believe i'm planting these
bonsai trees once i
finish dimed as unbreakable what should
i name the tree comment something down
below
anyways this story while i think it's
fundamentally different in its approach
when compared with stardust crusaders
battle tendency and
even phantom blood it's taken elements
from each of them and spliced them
together with its very own secret sauce
to create something entirely new
for instance there's a clear episodic
feeling to this story at least
early on in them encountering stance
however the frequency with which they
encountered these new stands
has decreased significantly since
stardust crusaders and the length of
these encounters feel much longer and
what's more is
much like battle tendency there's a
stronger connection to a goal and
progressive serialized format than what
status crusaders offered
heck even the small enclosed settings
that this arc marinates in feels
fittingly reminiscent of phantom blood's
first half too
however i think an element that makes
this arc feel all the more impressive
is once again how araki has chosen to
implement
his stance which while in part three the
fantastical elements and locations
within the story were complemented by
equally outlandish and crazy stand
powers
diamond as unbreakable decides to turn
that application
of stand ability execution on its head
while before in stardust crusaders the
bazaar was complemented by the amazing
to create a cohesive uniformity that
worked so well for that story being told
in this one araki ops to strip away all
of the fantastical elements of the world
but instead bathes it in the mundanity
of everyday suburban life
and while the setting is standard and
small scale it allows the mad genius
creativity of a rocky through his use of
stands to create an
easy whiplash effect on its readers in
other words the surroundings lull you
into a state of relaxation and
familiarity
not unlike a horror movie suddenly
getting quiet before something amazing
happens
which prime you for a visceral reaction
when you eventually see those
expectations blown out of the water when
something creepy
awesome mysterious or all three of those
things
happen it's a wonderful way of
approaching a story i think but in order
to help capture my experience going
through this story for you i'll run
through the events in order and give you
my thoughts
first up
[Applause]
jonaro meets josuke something i've
noticed that's become something of a
trend across all of these introduction
chapters to the stories
is that while endearing us to and
educating us on the new protagonists of
each arc
jonathan joseph jonero and now josuke is
that typically in some form or
expression they
involve other characters we've already
familiarized ourselves with
which is honestly interesting because
going into jojo's bizarre adventure day
one before i even
opened phantom blood i thought it was
incredibly unconventional to throw
caught into the wind and change your
protagonist at the beginning of every
new arc
i thought this would not only alienate
an audience but it might even drive some
know who you away but whatever the case
may be or circumstances in a given arc
you best believe there will always be
some remnants of the prior story or in
the case of diamond is unbreakable it
has
elements of past stories plural
that's right right off the bat we're
following the point of view of the prior
protagonist kujo joturo now searching
for an individual in a small town in the
middle of japan called
morio this story diamond is unbreakable
is set in 1999
but was written by iraqi in 1992. and
really it's not very noticeable apart
from the fact that most people still
have crazy 80s hair
and speaking of hair let's talk about
the new jojo taking center stage
it's none other than the kind-hearted
short-tempered and perfectly quaffed
josuke higashikata now 16 years old this
young man is pursued by the 29 year old
kujo jotaro who is
get this josuke's nephew let that sink
in
it's explained to us that he's the child
of joseph joestar
during a night of passion with one
tomoko despite him being married for
decades
and decades faithfully i would have
thought but i guess not despite this
decision being strange to me and
in that it really tears down joseph in
my estimation retroactively
i think it also offered a lot of
interesting opportunities later in the
story for some emotional and
intense moments but i'll get to that
later during these first few chapters
jotaro informs him that he's there to
investigate strange goings-on in the
small town
after joseph's hermit purple which is
just the most useful plot device
shows an insidious presence looming over
the area and thus are the circumstances
setting up this particular arc
and josuke gets a nice introduction too
by saving a turtle from some bullies and
beats them up and repairs them using his
stand this stand is called crazy diamond
it's super fast and can punch real good
but
interestingly can heal and recombine
what it has destroyed
leading to some of the most graphic
images
i've ever seen a protagonist from jojo
ever enact upon the cast of this story
interestingly i love that diamond is
unbreakable takes care to align itself
with the prior story in that dia was the
one to ignite the stand
inside josuke as when he was four years
old we are told
much like jodorow's mother holly he fell
ill for quite some time
it's a nice little attention to detail
but it went a long way in making this
feel more connected to the broader world
and this is where it gets good
and gory right after josuke and his
little new friend leave after their
chance encounter with jonaro
they encounter this dude with a hostage
josuke and angelo this was one of the
coolest things i've ever seen
and the best part is the main character
actually did that
and he healed him after i can't imagine
much would hurt more than that but
there you go this fellow that got
spit-roasted by josuke
was actually under the control of a
particularly small stand that can take
over the body through
water and he is owned by one angelo a
convicted criminal on death row that
managed to escape by some means that are
still
unknown to us this is the very first
major adversary jojo faces in this arc
and
served the story exceptionally well in
the wilder pretending to be different
people throughout the town enabling us
the audience to get to know the various
key characters like tomoko josuke's
mother
and his grandfather ryohei who become
the victims of this criminal's advances
once he sets his eyes on josuke and
jodaro after they interfered with his
good time earlier and sadly
his grandfather doesn't make it out of
this particular chapter
regarding angelo i thoroughly enjoyed
his devious behavior and the action that
ensued due to the absurd nature of his
stand power
manifesting out of nowhere like from
water bottles steam and
even the rain this guy would pop out of
nowhere and cause
all sorts of mayhem however not the sort
of mayhem that josuke and jodaro
couldn't take care of
turned into a rock thanks to the
inventive initiative of one josuke's
standpower
he eventually spills the beans at how he
managed to escape prison
and what would eventually become the
goal early on when he describes the
shadowy individual in a school uniform
that granted him his stand power in the
first place
by way of bow and arrow this becomes
incredibly interesting and now we have
an individual to be on the lookout for
that's pretty much haunting this town
great so now we have a vague target and
a goal which on top of giving the
audience something to shoot for
also clears up where all the other stand
users from part 3 came from
other than thin air outside of the
joestar family line
the nijimura brothers at this point in
the story i hope you're starting to
appreciate that while this sort of feels
episodic
the rate with which we receive new
information that progresses the main
story
is much more frequent than stardust
crusaders and so with diamond is
unbreakable continuing the trend of
edging closer to the truth comes one of
the coolest scenes
in the first half for me
after investigating this decrepit
building they find themselves caught in
a battle with these two individuals
called the nijimura brothers things take
a massively interesting turn for the
mysterious and dramatic when out of
nowhere josuke's new friend koichi is
almost killed by way of the arrow and
that's when we see
this this sent
shivers down my spine made to feel all
the worse and more disconcerting due to
how warm and familiar this suburban
setting
is this bow and arrow grants those that
are struck by it withstand powers but
it also comes at great risk those that
are not strong enough to sustain the
stand power
much like holly could run the risk of
dying and by the looks of it koichi
isn't going to make it
he's not strong enough but this is where
diamond is unbreakable strengths start
to show themselves
having seen josuke attempt to restore
his grandpa back to life after angelo
killed him we know that in order to save
koichi he
needs to start the healing process
before he fades away for good and the
only foes that seem to be standing in
his way are the nijimura brothers
this added stake and stipulation to the
battle really and truly makes for some
edge of your seat action
so far the story has reeled me in and
what's more is it's made me care about
these characters and impressed me with
how they've structured these scenes
you know you're doing something right
when as soon as araki had koichi struck
by the arrow my first reaction was
oh no but moments later i was able to
piece together that josuke
has the ability to save him it's a
wonderful feeling and it's carried out
so well in this section
josuke and the brothers do battle but
one of the brothers is saved by josuke
the climax of this battle brings us to
within a hair's breath
of retrieving the bow and arrow thanks
to in part the kind ninjimoto brother
okuyatsu he's not the brightest but he
appreciates josuke's virtuous nature and
joins him in his efforts but shockingly
they are pulled away
into a socket by way of some electrical
stand user he's made off with the bow
and arrow and okiyatsu's brother is gone
for good following this unsettling
encounter josuke and koichi as a result
of the conflict and actions taken
therein form a close friendship with
okayatsu
and then something i never saw coming
happened
the story ended and it's around this
point the show hits me with what it's
trying to do and
let me tell you it made me feel all the
more tense the following few groupings
of chapters aren't very plot focused and
instead lean heavily into the
development of characters and
or the exploration of the town of mario
in greater detail
this video is brought to you by
manscape.com every now and then a
sponsor lands on my desk that not only
catches my interest but is also a
perfect match for the video in question
jojo's bizarre adventure is filled with
super massive hairless dudes that no
doubt have the best body care on the
market
enter manscaped who hooked me up with a
bunch of tools and formulas for their
all-in-one performance package kit
nestled luxuriously beneath a canopy
that boasts the phrase your balls will
thank you were an assortment of devices
and formulas carefully curated to take
care of my unsightly body forest
first of all i endeavor to take
advantage of the new lawnmower 3.0
waterproof trimmer with advanced
skincare technology that's a mouthful
i found that it was surprisingly easy to
use smooth and easy on my skin which
has a tendency to be sensitive after
this manscape saw fit to supply me with
and bathe me in their sincerely named
ball deodorant called
crop preserver and a ball toner spray i
really liked
the next weapon i was armed with was
called the weed whacker nose and hair
trimmer
and let me tell you excalibur ain't got
nothing on this thing super comfortable
and very effective in use
for a limited time you can get this plus
two free gifts the shed travel bag and
the manscape anti-chafing boxer briefs
go to manscape.com today and get 20
off plus free shipping plus two free
gifts when you use the promo code tnm so
check out manscape.com today your balls
and your body
will thank you the mini arcs
the first of these minor sections covers
a short five chapter adventure of koichi
as he
yeah he cycles over some kittens which
by the way now that i'm talking about it
this arc feels
significantly more aged up than the
first three did there's some really
scary stuff here later that shook me to
my very core
this manga no longer feels like a shonen
to me now the point of this miniak is to
define koichi's character more clearly
by putting him up against a tame
opponent with an interesting stand but
more so to develop and establish how
koichi's stand is developing the prior
encounter in the old house with the
nijimura brothers koichi acquired a
stand but
as we saw it was an egg however in the
fight that erupts forth from this
section his egg finally hatches
and reveals reverb his stand which has
the really creative power of imprinting
onomatopoeia onto the target and forcing
that individual or object to hear or
make that sound
from that point onward and the drawings
in this section are awesome too it's a
really nice mini arc that helped me gain
so much more respect for koichi as a
character red hot chili pepper
this red hot chili pepper electricity
enemy while its wielder has been elusive
and
in the possession of the bow and arrow
that has been our goal this entire time
despite being immensely slippery and
powerful in his own right with some
really spectacular action that left me
on the edge of my seat throughout
seriously this battle and ultimately the
person wielding this stand doesn't have
much to do with the main story of this
arc but
the action and fighting in this part was
awesome and that's something this arc
has a lot of but what i will say about
diamond is unbreakable's beginning is
that it is a very long and slow burner
but that's not to say it's bad in fact
i loved it this is some of my absolute
favorite stuff from the series josuke's
power to recombine and restore something
is one of the most
fun powers i've ever seen put to paper
the possibilities with it are seemingly
endless and the means with which it
elevates fights is clear to see but this
meandering and almost aimless aspect to
the story was something i wasn't
expecting it really caught me off guard
and
it certainly became an issue after this
fight seeing as we now have technically
achieved our goal we defeated the
electricity dude
and have the bow and arrow now we won
the ark is over now
i'm gonna blitz through the next few so
that i can talk about something that
really really excited me later in the
story but more so because
it's not necessarily plot focused and
more character-driven so if you want the
character-driven stuff
i can't really explain that to you you
just gotta watch it for yourself and if
you've seen it already you don't need me
to go over it toshikazu hazamada yukako
falls in love
let's go eat some italian food yokako
yamagishi dreams of cinderella and
let's go to the manga artist's house are
all self-contained mini arcs that help
us explore the wider community within
the small town of moria and their
respective stand powers
they don't have anything to do with the
plot directly but
oh boy they will and what's more is now
that i've read up to a
certain point i think i know exactly why
araki wanted to show us all of these
people and their powers so
pay attention it's very important
toshikaza has amadeus chapters tell the
story of how josuke and koichi come into
conflict with him he's a regular student
with a twisted side and an even spookier
stand power which can turn
his marionette into a copy of whomever
it touches
and what's more is toshikaze can also
manipulate your own movements and
in the case of josuke tries to force him
into stabbing his own eye
however thanks to some quick thinking
and some wonderfully convincing sound
effects on behalf of koichi and reverb
josuke tricks him into thinking he has
stabbed his eye and eventually takes him
out
indirectly
in the end toshikaza repents for his
sins and they ultimately forgive him so
new party member sort of yokoko
yamagishi is the lucky recipient of two
mini arcs that center around her and her
antics
she's a tall beautiful dark-haired girl
and her introductory story involves her
confessing to cochi that she loves him
and this is where we really start to
understand her as a character all the
more she is essentially
obsessed with koichi and following a
rather cliche story in which koji
becomes overwhelmed by her and
eventually kidnapped
and the conflict arises as koichi you
know he tries to escape her stand power
is pretty cool too where she can use her
hair as appendages
in the end in conflict koichi chooses to
save her despite his dire situation
which puts him up in my estimation all
the more again
and she regressed what she did too so
i will not let you destroy i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm really sorry the second story
she's involved with begins as she
struggles with keeping her distance from
koichi which she promised she would do
after the last event once again
longing form what can i say this is very
clearly a female character written in
the early 90s
though in this part we do get to see her
engage with another female character
that runs a boutique that can
using her stand change and alter
someone's face this will become
incredibly important later yekuko
utilizes this to try and change her
appearance to gain the favor of koichi
yet again
it sort of works but not because she's
super hot but because she seems like a
more relaxed person and
he felt guilty about her feeling guilty
there's some creepy moments in here too
like her losing her face for a while
that happens overall i like these two
stories somewhat they weren't super
interesting but they were fine and they
served their job of introducing us to
this character and i like her let's go
eat some italian food is probably the
most simple of all these small stories
essentially okuyasu and josuke go get
some grub the grub has some crazy side
effects that are mostly positive for
okiyasu and
josuke is very suspicious it's a really
funny enjoyable mini arc that if you
haven't seen it i'd recommend it's one
of the funnier more lighthearted aspects
of the show and introduces us to
this chef and finally in let's go to a
manga artist's house
our newly acquired ally toshikazu tag
teams this one with koichi once again
who's getting an enormous amount of
shine as they decide to fanboy over this
popular manga artist's house and where
he lives in hopes to meeting him in real
life within the world of judge's bizarre
adventure he is an incredibly popular
mangaka and he goes by the name of rohan
kishibe and he happens to live in their
neighborhood too he's a little creepy
with a
really cool design and even creepier
power which allows him to read people's
life story like manga and is even able
to alter it directly affect the person
he targets
as you will soon see later as you can
see with this particular mini arc
araki's efforts are paying off
there's a considerable amount of time
being spent away from josuke which makes
him feel all the more important and
impactful when he does
eventually show back up in the story we
have all of these new characters
all over the town now that we're
familiar with and we have so many
different powers at our disposal
and this is also important because that
electricity-based stand that reclaimed
the bow and arrow we've been after all
this time earlier
that isn't even remotely what this story
is about
congratulations you've just graduated
diapers in the world of diamond is
unbreakable because
what happens after this is the real
story and it's
easily my favorite part of this arc and
any arc of any jojo pirate i've ever
seen
and it's not even close the serial
killer of mario
this story isn't one that concerns
itself with a quest or a series of
battles necessarily
it's a murder mystery as we take a
really interesting look into this town's
dark
dark history this part of the story
literally freaked me out
and achieved a sense of creepiness i
haven't seen in a manga before so
let's dive right in rohan's adventure
this is where things take a turn in this
quiet town from the mundane to the
strange and
eventually the unsettling introduced is
just another harmless adventure with the
likes of koichi and our new ally rohan
as the two stumble across an alleyway
with this girl they find themselves
stuck in effectively a dimension between
the living world and the dead but
that's not the interesting part while
it's horrific to see a dog's throat
sliced so graphically the unease comes
from this girl called remy
who reveals that she herself is a ghost
and that she was brutally murdered by
someone from mario
15 years ago and that he is still alive
and killing to this very day what a
twist
i love that this story sprung this
massive plot point out onto our laps out
of effectively nowhere all the while we
were expecting just another slice of
life chapter or episode
and this is not where this one ends
either just barely succeeding to get out
of this strange ghost dimension thanks
to the quick thinking and
nerves of rohan josuke is brought up to
speed on everything however
since this serial killer in question
isn't a confirmed stand user
he concludes that it's a job for the
police which is fair considering they've
been looking for
this looming evil over the town in the
form of a stand user all of this time so
it stands to reason
they want to remain focused and that's
when the manga does something
i really wasn't prepared for they
immediately revealed
the killer driving home from work
talking to someone in the passenger seat
makes small talk with his passenger
before he attempts to help her out of
the car seat
and that's when the camera pans out to
reveal a severed hand
the way he talks to it caresses it and
uses it for
whatever reason really stayed with me
and truly horrified me but what i found
interesting more than perhaps anything
else was how araki saw fit to structure
this particular encounter
his viewers now know who the killer is
almost immediately after finding out
that there was one
but no one else does this turned out to
be
a spectacular decision for later on
shigechi's harvest
once again we are greeted by another
standalone seven chapter story
introducing us to a new member of the
morio community called
shigechi pretty much taking the focus in
this section is relationship and overall
dynamic between the
at first seemingly sweet and innocent
shigechi and the duo of josuke
and okuyatsu short on money once they
learn of shigechi's stand power harvest
and its unique abilities they see an
opportunity to leverage their ideas with
his ability to get some quick cash
the plans go perfectly according to
josuke's plan
however unable to see josuk's utility
and feeling like he did all the work
he didn't shigechi hoards all of the
earnings for himself while throwing some
change towards jojo and his friend this
takes a turn for the worse when they
suddenly realize that they've won a
lottery ticket naturally things escalate
from here and climax in a stand battle
with josuke okiatsu
and shigechi they fight in another
terrifically unique battle with some
terrifically clever implementations of
josuke's ability which
the longer this story goes on for the
more and more i fall in love with this
particular ability and its utility
within a story
the best way for him to take charge of
this particular situation in dealing
with this surprisingly powerful harvest
stand was when he ripped up
the winning lottery ticket in front of
everyone making him
suddenly the most important person and
the only one who can bring the winnings
back to reality
shigechi learns a valuable lesson and
the three friends go on to the next day
with their winnings and a newfound
respect for one another
yoshikage kira wants to live a quiet
life everything else from here on is
nothing but
suspense horror and action and i think
it should go without saying that it's my
absolute favorite part of this arc so
far
kicking things off perfectly by once
again making me totally grossed out by
this kira character as he punctures and
purchases a sandwich with a severed hand
under his coat however things take a
turn for the surprisingly interesting
and tense when shigechi accidentally
takes his bag containing the rotting
severed hand
of his most recent victim and as a
result a direct dna and fingerprint tie
to kira as the serial killer of morio
because of this the episode now employs
two
great writing techniques some of my
favorites alfred hitchcock's bomb under
the table
and dramatic irony in the case of this
scene we know that the bag will
eventually be placed into
plenty of scenarios where kira runs the
risk of being discovered and we are
waiting for that moment all the while
occupying kira's point of view and
wondering what he might do if it is
exposed secondly and finally dramatic
irony preys
on the knowledge of the audience and the
lack of awareness in the characters on
screen
we know what's in the bag but shigechi
josuke and okuyasu
don't it makes it all the more tense as
we have no idea what kira might do
if they see it well i mean one could
only assume right
okay we're fighting i guess kira stand
is called
killer queen and in my opinion is the
perfect foil and compliment to josuke's
crazy diamond where josuke's heals and
restores something to its original form
this killer queen specializes in turning
everything it touches
into bombs and this is when one of the
most depressing scenes in the first half
lens
staggering on the verge of death in a
bloody heap
through a hallway of his own school
people pass him by
ignoring him not wanting to get involved
until he manages to pull himself up
and touches the door handle to josuke's
classroom
[Music]
this is what i was talking about earlier
when i knew what araki was doing within
morio he wanted us to feel some sort of
connection to these characters and for
us to feel the loss when kira ripped
them away from the pages of this story
it's super effective but there was a
small miscalculation on kira's part
one last gambit on behalf of shigechi
and harvest he stole a button from
kira's suit and delivered it straight to
josuke
unbeknownst to kira exceptional use
of the stand power not just because it's
a neat idea to maintain the string of
events but because this is a small town
and with this lead the gang have a good
chance of encountering kira when he goes
to get his suit jacket repaired and
interestingly in the next scene when
they are pursuing kira
the two characters we're following are
jodoro and koichi in their very first
team up as they investigate the origin
of this button
and as luck would have it his jacket is
right there
finally a turn up for the books they
seem to be moments from cracking this
case when
the brutality of this scene is
phenomenal and what's more is
the killer is right here in this
building which means it's time for
killer queen and star platinum to duke
it out i guess
this kira character with his killer
queen isn't simply a one-trick pony
either pulling out his brand new
automated land drone that seeks out heat
signatures and explodes on impact the
only time a character has performed in
any meaningful way after their
introductory arc has been joseph
in stardust crusaders but with joseph
being so much older in that section and
with it all containing a new power
system taking hold
joseph felt significantly nerfed as a
result however
in this battle sequence with heart
attack jodaro feels
just as powerful as he ever has
utilizing everything he's come to be
known for
a cool head clever tactics leadership
qualities and brute
force something i think is important to
expand upon at this point is that
unlike joseph not using hammond much as
titus crusaders and as a result feeling
useless by comparison
jotaro very much feels powerful and
capable
even someone all the characters in this
park can look up to and for heart attack
a part of kira's stand power to give
him that much trouble was shocking and
believable considering jodaro's power
set
[Music]
left in a bloodied heap on the floor
clinging to consciousness
jotaro's life is in koichi's hands
however understandably at this point i'm
thinking to myself
how could koichi do what joduro couldn't
well the answer is
he can't but what he can do is utilize
information we know about the heart
attack drone already
and leverage that through clever tactics
to buy time and call for backup
specifically to call josuke honestly i
think koichi stand is one of my
favorites out of all of the ones i've
come across so far in the series he
managed to find a weakness that jodorow
couldn't exploit and that's not all
following the trend that's been
established throughout this act so far
reverb further matures and digivolves
into act
three with a whole new set of powers a
brand new look he acts as another
mystery box for both us as an audience
and koichi to hope and pray
he has some sort of new power that can
be useful against this indestructible
heart attack
and he does this little guy has the
single most useful move
ever the best part is it directly
affects kira's character someone that
always wants to keep a low profile now
has his hand crushed through
a table and has everyone now looking for
him thanks to this incredible new
technique kira is forced to return to
the battlefield along with killer queen
to finish what he started
in person with all of this being put
onto koichi's shoulders all the while
juggling the abilities of a new stand
he's still coming to grips with was such
a tense time
however he managed to do what no one
else was able to do expose kira
enraged by this he flattens koichi and
moves on
to the killing blow
i jumped out of my chair when i saw this
i thought koji was so gonna die
we are not out of the woods yet not by a
long shot jodoro is on the verge of
collapse and kira can sense
and feel that in his blows thankfully
however
jotaro can unbeknownst to kira stop time
and attack then and attack he does
landing blow after blow
after blow jotaro knocks out kira before
falling to the floor himself
unconscious and as luck would have it
this is when josuke stumbles into the
equation time to heal the party and
oh my god are you seriously gonna heal
this guy
this moment when josuke came so so damn
close to healing kira
had my stomach in nuts and thankfully
josuke isn't a dumb character and
actually
logics his way out of this one in a
really impressive way
kira has screwed up in this instance but
by using his heart attack drone once
again he manages to
just about escape and this is where once
again araki impresses me
beyond all measure with his utter stupid
genius
josuke once again showing us the
tremendous utility of his stand
instead of fighting the drone he heals
it which forces it
to fly back towards kira thus outing his
whereabouts once again
allowing the crew to find where he is
and now all they gotta do is follow this
drone and
oh jokes aside i've said genius a lot
but this
was seriously genius he now has a new
face
thanks to this woman that we've already
been introduced to he's killed this
woman
and now he's missing after assuming a
new identity
my favorite part about this conclusion
is that this is a rocky making full use
of
his medium and the jojo property when it
was revealed that there was a killer on
the loose
and then immediately later kira was
revealed to us i genuinely was both
confused and impressed
typically speaking the fun of a whodunit
story comes from speculating as to the
whereabouts
and the identity of the killer but he
decided to reveal him
right up front and with that a host of
new possibilities were explored and
enjoyed by us
namely a number of tense encounters from
the killer's point of view but
thanks to the stand of one user thanks
to the way
jojo's bizarre adventure is written
araki can now enjoy his cake and eat it
too he could now have had that story
that he explored with kira just now and
he can now have a whodunit story with
the killer on the loose without us
having a clue
as to what he looks like and honestly
that blew me away
next week the finale of this arc is
gonna be truly
[Music]
you